[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute gibt es wieder
leckere noweck schnitten ich weiß ja
dass wir alle gerade bei warmen
temperaturen obey kräfte liebt und
insbesondere wenn es schnitten sind und
da hab ich mal so richtig schönes
überlegt das werden wir nicht so denn
orange mond orangen mond auf jeden fall
wenn die weitere namensvorschläge
treffen wir die kommentare dann kann ich
den titel auch gerne noch nach euren
wünschen ändern auf jeden fall machen
wird dafür jetzt zuallererst einen
pudding putin schnitten pudding
schnitten wir auch eine idee gewesen
egal hauptsache es schmeckt also wir
starten jetzt direkt mit dem pudding und
dafür nehmen wir uns also ich stehe zwar
am herd aber da ist noch ausgeschaltet
und ich schreibe immer ganz genauen
mengenangaben und nene infobox ich sage
ernst fuchs weil wir das hier noch zum 1
mrk nein sagst ja so als er selbst das
ist die banken auf jeden fall gebe ich
hiermit rein so zum ich gebe ich
speisestärke zucker und 1 eigelb und
verrührt das jetzt erst mal vorab
miteinander
[Musik]
so hinzu kommt jetzt noch marmelade dann
nämlich von schäfers frutti orange das
original englische orangenmarmelade und
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch an das
video mit dem namen köpft liebe ja auch
das lenkrad von jeffers und da nehme ich
einfach gefragt hey möchtest du dem noch
mal ein rezept für uns einfallen lassen
und ich hab doch natürlich klar denn ich
mag das total gerne und es ist ja auch
so dass durch eine zutat sich so die
ganze idee aufbaut und ich hatte dieses
mal mit lager und probieren immer
gedacht okay schmeckt sehr fruchtig sehr
nach orange passend dazu mache ich ein
pudding geht monat zugleich gebe ich
noch vanille dazu und ich habe das schon
mal vor nicht gebacken backen tut man
sich nicht schon mal vorbereitet und es
hat uns allen sehr gut geschmeckt und
passt auch super gut zum sommer und das
einzige was sie jetzt noch machen müsst
genau vanille extrakt nicht vergessen
ist eine gute kombination
und also ganze jetzt nochmal verrühren
den herd einschalten und dann immer
dranbleiben immer höheren und sobald es
auf kocht dick dass ein dass sie keine
speisestärke und dann haben eigentlich
ein großteil ja schon geschafft und so
ein richtiges bild ritter freute
[Musik]
ich hatte in allen gedeckten pudding
direkt vom herd gezogen und mohn
untergerührt danach einfach nur stehen
lassen zwischendurch gern mal umrühren
und zwar 15 minuten damit so ein
bisschen ausdampfen kann es jetzt noch
lauwarm und da gebe ich auch schon die
mascarpone mit dazu dass die letzte
zutat für unseren äckern putting auch
einrühren und dann können wir eigentlich
schon an die form gehen und das ganze
schichten so ich habe jetzt die erste
ladung kekse auf dem boden gegeben ich
habe hier auch noch unten drunter ein
backpapier und darunter einen torten
retter dann hat er einfach die perfekte
konstruktion und jetzt geben wir auch
noch den lauwarmen pulling darauf der
sollte auch lauwarm sein damit eben die
kekse dadurch ein bisschen einweichen
können und auch die oberen kekse die
kommen welche direkt oben drauf damit
sie in der rest sei eben nicht mehr so
knackig bleiben sondern schön weich
werden
[Musik]
die schnitten geben wir dann für
mindestens drei stunden in den
kühlschrank wenn sie auch noch mal
richtig schön fest und in der
zwischenzeit habe ich die sahne steif
geschlagene mit sahne fest und ein
bisschen vanille extrakt und das traue
ich dann später für die deko und jetzt
das ist mir so weit mir ist alles schön
abgekühlt ich nehme jetzt hier nochmal
eine backform löser um mit den bug raum
zu entfernen und mir die schlitten hat
auch nicht kaputt zu reifen und danach
der kurier ich mit der vorbereiteten
sahne und ich nehme noch ein paar
orangen stücke mit dazu damit so ein
kleiner hinweis ist was sich quasi in
der polin creme versteckt
[Musik]
ich habe passiert jetzt
die sind vor allem auf meinen teller
mehr zogen also extra dass das passt ja
ja bist du ein super feiert dieses
trikot hosen fall also ich hab halt den
hansa geholt vielen tasty hatte gesehen
dass der keks supersoft ist der wird
auch sofort soft wegen im warmen pudding
war sehr erfrischend ich bin super froh
sein regime nicht direkt erst langsam
ein erfrischend du spinnst du sonst
könnten wir süße her weil der keks hat
ja auch schon süße und dem ganzen ganzen
problem nur 100 gramm zucker was
eigentlich fast gar nichts ist also egal
was du mitmachst ja ich konnte alles ist
ich liebe montag dann deswegen kritisch
für den 10.10 von seen erforschung
erreichbar ist ein betreiber kuchen
sondern butterkeksen haben genau wo man
merkt doch ein bisschen frucht also das
hört ist schon heute werden die
orangenmarmelade drin und dann sehe ich
gerade ein also es ist spannend ob es
schmeckt auch so fruchtig und zusammen
mit dem mond mit der vanille geniale
kombination wie du sowas und kaffee
bekommen freuen ja ist mal was anderes
not sind und vor allem hält er sich
jetzt im kühlschrank auch bis zu vier
tage aber ich glaube nicht dass das so
lange du hast es keine gelatine sowas
necken
dabei kommuniziert das aussehen ist
ultrafast und nacht nur die speisestärke
also unbedingt nachmachen so gerade auch
in summe also ich muss keine angst haben
dass williams oder so das absolut nicht
der kann auch wenn ihr ein buffet habt
oder so auf dem tisch der kann ruhig da
zwei drei stunden dann stehen das macht
mir überhaupt nichts aus
danke danke schön ist denn gerne ganz
kalt aus dem kühlschrank man ist ja noch
mal extra erfrischend kleiner tipp von
mir
wir können uns derzeit seinen kaffee und
ich würde mal sagen abonniert den kanal
wenn es nicht schon längst getan habt
dann wieder bestimmt also schon also ich
wünsche euch noch einen
wunderschönen tag und bis zum nächsten
mal auf die couch in chips groß prost
wie wir immer nach dem auto eigentlich
beginnt um 17 uhr und dann stehen wir
hier noch in essen waiblingen immer
losgeflogen
[Musik]
das war so schlecht dass es schon gut
war
[Musik]